have you ever stopped to take a look at
people's pants they can do many things
some help others point and there are
those that help or they may repair
watches what at this moment these are
the hands of passion I want you to be
exciting
maybe so but serious is the better word
to describe the action that sees two men
train their hands for there are people
living who would say the seas all the
most important past in the world
and if you will permit me a little
posting I help them every now and then
and train to do their work
now you can tell immediately when N is
ferrous or the first class argument and
it's as far over as he can in the
driver's seat and flowers Clarence it's
over next to the other door and from
their argument this time at the scene of
an accident what are the most serious
kind of injuries and what can be done to
keep people alive until they are in safe
hands at the hospital
Thank You Suzanne
okay fellas so you don't agree about the
right treatment for seriously injured
people to tell you the truth I'm glad
you don't your argument gives me a
chance to give you some information that
should clear up a lot of
misunderstanding to begin with there is
nothing new about injury since the
beginning of time man has had to care
for injuries to his body the injury
received by a cave man who loses a
battle with a dinosaur and the injury
received because of an accident say was
a forklift truck are alike in all but
one way what is different is that
today's people are able to get better
treatment for their injuries you are
concerned with getting the injured
person from the place he was injured to
the place where they can get this
improved treatment in the best possible
condition the care and transportation of
injured people must be done by you
without causing further injury I want
you to think about four critically
important points or things that you
could see on your next emergency run
they are one blocked airway breathing
passages which become blocked and make
breathing difficult or impossible to
bleeding
three open wounds before last of all
broken bones
now laboratories have a way of giving us
the whys and wherefores of almost any
problem so let's see what we can uncover
about these four let's step right over
into this next row right after you
gentlemen
klaren Edie I think you'll be interested
in that
pathology in Airway is the path leading
from the nose and ball to the law when
it becomes blocked the flow of air into
the lungs it slowed down or stopped and
as this occurs the injured person may
die is just a few minutes there are many
things that can block Airways sometimes
the items are swallowing such as a piece
of steak
you name it has been found in someone's
wrong it more often than not the
obstruction is water product or blood
but any of these objects or material can
cause a man to die from lack of air just
the same as if he been smothered with a
flagon oh this is how a person breathe
see how the air flows freely to the lung
and return now they are youth gulp tea
and believe me golf tees have been found
lodged in throat this will be our object
here
right in the throat there are flows out
to sea stage is set for suffocation now
and the object is removed think
breathing can then become normal again
now frequently the obstruction is
bleeding that is located so that the
blood flows into the airway this can
occur when a fractured face breaks the
blood vessel or if the person bond or
when a rib breaks a blood vessel or in
many other way die it's worse if he
placed on his back see how the blood
could run from a broken nose right into
the loss muscles of the throat are
arranged so that any object in the
throat causes them to tighten up and
prevent the air from being inhaled into
the law all the solution to the problem
of a blocked airway is simple
remove the obstruction don't let it
happen again Suzanne would you bring in
bonding yes all right now to remove a
small object being well-known methods of
turning outside I'm sorry
while these will usually work but well
it can be dangerous if there are other
interests
they even caused more damage to the
person by these back or if you help me
off get up here please
all right come on over bring the car
down that there over on your side
ah the best way to take the object out
of the airway is to reach in with your
fingers and pull it out now this is
particularly true when the object is
visible not live deep in the throat a
happy injured man on inside and open his
mouth right there you can see the
obstruction then pull it out if the
material is blood vomit or something
like that then turn his head to the side
and clear you small in this way one of
the most valuable services you can
perform for an injured person is to
prevent his airway from becoming blocked
using bleeding from the power nose five
tears or or some other reason you
suspect that the injured person may have
internal bleeding then he should be
transported light thing on his side okay
glance thank you tapas
let's think about bleeding
how much blood do you have in your body
but normally the body contains five for
it to the three courts are lost a person
usually done to show you how much blood
I'm talking about what's it
person can lose this much blood and live
he loses more you may die by cutting a
large artery a person can lose that
amount in just about ten minutes this is
why it's so important for you learn
today and all their attendants to treat
bleeding quickly now how is this blood
move about in the body circulate all
right let's use this model and we'll
demonstrate now the heart is the pump of
our circulatory system when the heart
beat is tightened up and blood squeeze
from it and through the blood vessels of
the body as what leaves the heart is
pulses through the artery now they are
the pipeline that carry the blood from
the heart to the rest of the body in the
arteries the blood is bright red and
groans in first and jump it then travels
through the capillaries which are very
very small blood vessels now the last
step in this circulation process is the
return of the blood to the heart through
the vein when the blood travels through
the vein it moves in a smooth flowing
stream and it has a dark red color if we
cut an artery blood comes out in spurts
if a vein is cut it flows out smoothly a
solids remember that bleeding can occur
inside the body as well as on the
surface it's important that you
recognize bleeding and know how to stop
first medical schools
little bleeding is a common event like
to use a film from our medical school to
look asleep
this is actual bleeding from an artery
and a vein notice the hole in the artery
made by the scissors its leaves bright
red blood in sperm the bleeding can be
stopped by direct pressure with a finger
over the hole the vein bleeds thought
red blood in a steady stream it too can
be stopped by direct pressure arteries
spurt bright red veins flows dark red
both can be stopped by pressure on the
reading area
but let me show you something else to
thought bleeding and it's control come
on over here
alright now this represents wool
the water flowing from this hose can be
compared to please and put your hand
over to stop it
you can pinch the hose across a whole
battles office or you can take some
adhesive tape for Billy I've seen all
this talking
now these are the same methods you can
use to control bleeding let me show you
how these methods work Susanne ban him
that realization
now this accident occurred when the
Tremont this is footing fell on a broken
jaw the ambulance was called by a radio
telephone and we will see how the
attendants control severe bleeding they
first find out what the injury is and
the man of general condition
when they are satisfied that there is no
worse injury than the bleeding they will
try to stop it there is the jar that did
it that's an artery leading the mother
blood rushes off to stop the bleeding he
will apply direct pressure on the client
using a gauze pad and his hand
notice here that these pads are too
small
he needs a much larger one the
pale-faced shows that he has lost a lot
of blood and he may be in shock
they are now wrapping an elastic bandage
tightly over the gauze pad this keeps
the bleeding under control
watch him is a panty just twist
occasionally see he does this to keep
the edges tight
he also pulls on the elastic bandage to
put pressure on the world the bandage
should be very tight
they keep wrapping until the bleeding
stopped
with the bleeding stopped the attendants
carry the injured man to the ambulance
and then to a hospital
I'll talk about the trouble with
tourniquet in a minute but first let's
review some point how did the men know
it was an artery that was cut blood with
rye bread it was coming out at first
that's right but he remembered that when
the blood left the heart had traveled
through the arteries it was under
pressure moved along and cuts or spurs
and have been a vein that was higher
then the blood would have been darker
and would have flowed smoothly another
fact for you to remember is that the
pressure was applied above the wool in
the case of an artery since the blood
was flowing from the heart to the wall
and had been a vein then to stop the
bleeding
he would apply the pressure below the
wall now upon Charrington Suzanne would
you help me I want to demonstrate this
predicates should be applied only when
other methods fail remember this if
nothing else works then you apply the
tourniquet one arm or leg that
represents our predicate as the wound
here is B and then we twist it until a
blood flow ceases there's a foot roller
another new very important do not
release the tourniquet once it is a
clock this is a job to be done at the
hospital thank you to that
no possible injury is an internal
hemorrhage or sis's bleeding that is
hidden or contained in the sides of life
how were these injuries we may not see
any blood or even if we do it may be
only a small amount
ahem regional lung often occurs when the
body slams into something like a bank or
a wall panelist Victor
if the injured person is placed on his
fat blob will collected as long and it
is possible for him to drown in his own
blood
the first position to placed on when
greeting from the nose or mouth is lying
on his side with his mouth more than his
loss this may not appear to be a
comfortable position but believe me it's
the best one placing the person bleeding
from the nose or mouth on his side may
be the most important thing you will do
to save his life
now let's talk about a situation I'm
sure you face more often than you like
involves rules that are severe and open
they require immediate attention yes
would you put up our next point please
on the board now the danger with open
wounds is an infection they fall so
clean dressings clean hands and avoiding
touching open wound are the things to
remember this looks familiar it also
now if you've ever put a patch on one of
these like this and of course you have
some idea of how a bandage work what
we're doing when we use a bandage is
applying a temporary patch on the body
to prevent dirt from getting into the
wool Suzanne would you give me that box
a sterile compress like this is the best
thing to use for them now of course
there other things you can use such as
adhesive tape or elastic bandages now
the famish is used may vary from one
type of wool to another but the
principle remains the same keep the
wound clean and to follow this rule the
things you need to do our first of all
do not touch the wound with your hand
secondly cover the wound in the area
around it with something that is clean
and third keep the edges of the families
tight against the skin so this dirt
cannot get in fellas if you do not have
a first-aid kit a fan these can be
anything that is clean that will do the
job for you
for instance voila sheet a cloth napkin
handkerchief piece of clothing like this
flip once these things are not as ideal
as the sterile contract now but examine
situations in which applying bandages
was necessary and watch other bandages
are put on add would you put on the
protectively
the first thing the attendants do is
examine all of the injured men and
decide the order of treating them this
man has a sucky boy it happened when he
fell on a drill and punctured his check
that torch on the scaffold caused this
verb
don't touch burn the danger of infection
is too great and you can't do anything
to help in spite of all the blood this
cut is not too serious and can wait
until arrest of the people of been
examined and the worst of the injuries
have been taken care of a piece of sheet
metal has cut through this man's belly
those are his intestines sticking up the
attendant is raising his knees to relax
the stomach muscle this helps keep the
pressure off the intestines and would
notice that someone remains with this
fan to help protect the wound until the
attendants return they must treat the
sucking wolf birth
the air coming through the poles is
caused two things the lung will collapse
or dirt and trash could be sucked into
the checker this is why his injury is so
urgent
first the hole is sealed with a piece of
adhesive tape
then a large sterile dressing is put
over the patch and taped down tightly
the tape over the dressing should also
help seal out there the edges of the
tape overlap each other and are pressed
down tightly
the gasping for air is not unusual
because only one lung is working you can
also expect bleeding from the nose or
mouth like you have here
the next most serious injury is the
intestine that is picking up infection
of this one could kill this man so don't
touch it
leave the intestine out keep your hands
off of it and apply a sterile dressing
don't do anything that will cause four
of the intestine to come out like
pushing on his chest or stomach taste
the dressing quickly enough do all the
intestine still but not fight the enough
to push it back into the world carry
this man on his back not on his side
or face down with burns like this there
is nothing you can do
infection is the greatest problem here
so keeping your hands off the burn is
bet don't put any dressing on take him
to the hospital as he in this cut only
needs a sterile dressing
if possible use a large dressing on
these cuts it's better to have one too
large than one too small this is a size
which you should keep in your ambulance
elastic band aid holds the dressing
inflate put it on tightly since there
was no spurting blood it's not likely
than any major artery would cut this
type of injury often looks more serious
than it really is
now let's review the steps these
attendants followed in each case they
check carefully to see what kind of wool
they had to work with then they selected
the correct family they were careful not
to cut the baby
where is touch the wolf then the bandage
was applied so that it overlapped the
injured area it did not put any ointment
or medicine on the Lord they left that
for the doctors to do stop what do we do
when we find a person for something
sticking in it good question plant the
answer is leave it alone if and in the
cowboy movies you find an arrow or any
other object sticking in a person does
take the person and the object to the
doctor don't take it out or cram it in a
good rule to follow is this one
don't touch a woman if he's all passive
about the bandages you put on will only
last to the hospital the doctors will
strip them off your job is to see that
the injured person arrives in as good a
condition as possible and not to tie up
pretty bad in which you put up our
fourth and final point broken bones
now the broken bone or fracture is an
injury that you will often see the
scenes common doesn't make it any less
trouble to take care of broken bones can
vary from an uncomfortable inconvenient
injury to a very serious injury
requiring surgery bone injuries can and
do cause death you are sometimes in a
position to save a life or limb by doing
the right thing
you can cross death with károly but
handling broken bone there are two main
types of broken bones for all the
fractures and open fracture
it represents the bone and a closed
fracture is one in which the sharp ends
of the broken bone do not come through
the skin if the sharpened the broken
bone do come through the skin then it's
an open fracture
our close branches can vary what it
differ those graduates can vary from a
small crack in the ball like this all
the way to a bone that is shattered
usual symptoms of a broken bone are
swelling and unusual twists of the limb
tenderness and fame and a good way to
find out if a person has a fracture is
to ask you murder now an open fracture
is more obvious but it poses a different
problem for you
the danger of infection is great because
of the exposed sharp foam and even
gangrene and loss of the limb could
occur there two rules for the care of
all pleasures and some special rules for
open fractures now rule number one split
all suspected fractures and rule to
split them where they lie that is where
you fight our split can be heavy
material that you want to use it will
hold a broken bone and plate
and there are reasons you immediately
splint suspected fracture first of all a
small amount of body movement can cause
the sharp ends of the broken bones of
punch through the scans us changing a
clove fracture to an open fracture
secondly splitted fractures are less
painful and third there is less damage
to surrounding muscles and other
shows and therefore less shock to the
patient when the fracture is plenty
plenty of easy if you understand the
idea you put something rigid around the
break to keep the bones from moving
blame materials are no trouble to find
for instance uh well we have packaged
splint limbs from trees magazines
blankets pillows or just some I can
think of offhand let me show you this
and bring over the blanket and the
magazine so give you a good idea yeah a
blanket rolled from each hand
Jordan the center we made into a splint
like they was it's left magazines to be
inter folded like this
and then flat and wouldn't get me that I
hadn't leaning against the powder there
or behind the scalp there that's the
Thomas this is a traction splint
followed and I'm going to ask you to
help me with the demonstration Clarence
would you come around here should have
two men for flying this splint and it
works by the pole that it puts on the
limb and get up here on the table
another it has this reversible metal
link that means that you can use it on
either leg also this buckle should be on
the outside good
now the metal wearing is placed
underneath log against the pelvis and of
course then this is buckle down very
tightly during Clarence pull pull very
hard on that
that keeps the leg in traction now what
we're going to do it we're babies tie
the leg at the bottom was splint by
using an angle hitch regular knot
and it's around thunder and loop it and
then this is tried that's it keep
pulling on it outside and tie to the end
of the splint and that keeps the leg in
traction that's very fine thank you
remember they flee the shoe on thank you
boys applying the splint
to the injury is not difficult at all
what you're doing is you're tying it
down tightly enough so the bone will not
move all right now I want you to look at
some pictures that show the splitting of
a planter Suzanne would you turn on our
projector again please
this girl was injured on water-ski her
leg was fractured at the shinbone
the two most important rules about open
fractures are one
don't touch the wound or both and two
don't pull or push the ball back in
leave it out you should apply a large
sterile compress the world to keep out
dirt notice how he raises the leg to
allow the other person to put the
bandage on
be gentle if you pull very hard the ends
of the bone will go back here this will
happen to you a lot of time wrapping
around the contract should be tight
enough to hold it in place and stop
bleeding but not tight enough to push
the bone back in you should not use a
Thomas splint on an open fracture below
the knee however it should be used on
any fracture of the thigh but don't use
too much traction if the bones stick
through the skin here they used in or
for a splint a stick or a tree limb
would do as well it's better to have a
splint too long that one too short you
must keep the broken bone from moving
the split is held firmly to the leg by
elastic bandages or any other wrapping
material that will do the job the pain
with broken bones can be very severe but
good splitting can help and may prevent
shock you should remember this the
bandage is to keep out infection and
stop bleeding the splint is to keep the
bone from moving if you even think the
bone is broken split it
this girl is ready to be moved
oh you've seen the way to splinter
fracture I don't want to leave the
subject of fractures without emphasizing
that your most important act is to keep
the broken bone from sticking through
the skin if you let it happen
you can't do enough things right to make
up for the damage you've caught
now the open fracture is flitted
identically to the closed fracture but
the special rule is to cover the exposed
roll and for the clean dressing to
prevent a further introduction of
surface cracks into the wolf do not and
I repeat it it will not push Bonin back
into the wound as this carries dirt eat
into the wall so if the neck on the back
is the suspected area of a fracture or
broken bone then you will have to use
great care this represents the back bone
called a spinal column and the spinal
cord running through it now any damage
to this cord in God permanent paralysis
for death now if the bone or two is
broken there's a possibility that any
movement can cause the final cord to be
damaged injured parts would you get up
here please and then fly back straight I
want to show you the manner in which to
handle a suspected fracture of the neck
keep the head straight does not allow it
to twist the way to do this is to always
have one person pull on the head and the
chin while the others moved to buy a
plate the fingers behind the head with
the thumb on the chin pull hard and keep
the chin up do not move the head to the
side or tilt it forward thanks man
we talked about four very important
point right now I want to talk about
something else it's just pigeon my boots
again fellas I have to go the fellas I
helped you would you mind helping me
with all these demonstrations we've had
here in the lab it's not very good
condition for tomorrow so would you mind
giving Susanna hand I'll see the harm